[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهداء في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من الرباط حيث تواصل الجماهير
المغربيه الاحتفالات بتاهل منتخبنا الى
الدور الثاني من مونديال قطر 2022 متصدرا
مجموعته
وفي ستات خليفه بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه
تجري مباراه منتخب اسبانيا واليابان من
اجل كسب بطاقه التاهل للدور الثاني من كاس
العالم الحاليه
وفي ستاد البيت في مدينه الخور يعود منتخب
المانيا وكوستاريكا الى مباراتهما وسط
اشتداد للتنافس من اجل التاهل لدور ال 16
عن المجموعه الخامسه
في مواضيع الحصاد
روسيا والغرب
العالميه الحلف يتوعد بالدفاع عن جميع
اعضائه يتحدث عن ضروره صياغه نظام امني
جديد للقاره قمه امريكيه فرنسيه
اذا اظهر رغبته بانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
العمليه التركيه الشماليه سوريا مزيد من
القصف والجدل ان قرات تكثف استهداف مواقع
في الياف حلب والحسك والرقه مجلس الامن
القومي التركي يؤكد انه سيتم اتخاذ
الخطوات اللازمه لمنع نشاط ما وصفه
بالتنظيم الارهابي وتنتجون يقول ان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي التركي عن معارضه واشنطن
القويه لاي غزوه بريه محتمل في شمال سوريا
وقائد ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
يطالب موسكو بموقف اكثر حزما من التصعيد
على وقع تصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه قوات الاحتلال تقتل
قياديين من حركه الجهاد في اقتحام لمدينه
جنين الحركه تتوعد بالرد وهيئه البث
الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن حاله استنفار في
غلاف غزه تحسبا لرد انتقاميا الليله ولبيد
يهدد بمواصله بمحاربه مواصفه بالارهاب دون
هذا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على من
الرقميه ناقشنا تاهل المنتخب المغربي الى
الدور الثاني من كاس العالم قطر 2022
وتصدره مجموعته للمره الثانيه في تاريخه
بعد دوره المكسيك عام 86 وكيف حظيت
المنتخبات العربيه المشاركه بتشجيع غير
مسبوق من الجماهير العربيه باستطلاعيه
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هي عوامل الاصطفاف
الجماهير العربيه مع اي منتخب عربي
28% قالوا ان السبب هو تميز اداء العربي
بينما ارجع واحد 41% الامر الى اقامه
المونديال في بلد عربي في حين ارجعه واحد
31% الى الامرين معنا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
وبعض الحصاد مباشره و تحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الشرقيه لافروف
ان الولايات المتحده جعلت اوكرانيا
التهديدا وجوليا لبلاده واعتبر الوزير
الروسي في مؤتمر صحفي منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا كيانا هامشيا ياتي هذا
في وقت ينعقد في بولندا الاجتماع السنوي
لوزاره الخارجيه المنظمه لبحث تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا بدوره وجه الامين العام
للنيتور رساله الى موسكو بانه سيدافع عن
كل حليف له خاصه في الجانب الشرقي للحلف
بين مقتضيات الحرب على اوكرانيا وجدل
الفاعليه والجدوى ينطلق في بولندا لاجتماع
السنوي لوزراء خارجيه منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا
بمشاركه 57 بلدا من تلك البلدان فرقاء
الحرب الاوكرانيه بمنفيهم روسيا التي منع
وزير خارجيتها من الحضور باعتباره وفق
التبرير البولندي مشمولا بعقوبات اوروبيه
اتهم الولايات المتحده العضو بالمنظمه
بانها جعلت اوكرانيا تهديدا وجوديا لبلاده
واعتبر منظمه الامن والتعاون كيان مشرفا
على الزوال بفعل الدول كبولاندا رئيسه
الدوله الحاليه
ثقافه التوافق
تاس منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا منتصف
سبعينيات القرن الماضي وهي اكبر منظمه
حكوميه دوليه ذات توجه امني تعنى بقضايا
الحد من التسلح وتعزيز حقوق الانسان وحريه
الصحافه ونزاهه الانتخابات لكن التداعيات
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تدفع كما يبدو
الشركاء الاوروبيين في المنظمه نحو صياغه
نظام امني جديد اشار اليه مفوض السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
في معرض حديثه عما وصفها بجرائم روسيا في
اوكرانيا
عبر جهود المشتركه متعدده الاطراف لتمهيد
الطريق لاقامه امنيا جديده في اوروبا ودعم
مقترح جديد لانشاء محكمه خاصه بجرائم
الحرب في اوكرانيا
وفي تغريده لاحقه الله اتهم بريل روسيا
بنتهاك وثيقته السينكي التي تاسست عليها
منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا عام
1975 يروج الاوروبيون كثيرا لمقترح
المحكمه الخاصه بجرائم الحرب في اوكرانيا
فهي وفق مسؤولهم السبيل الموصله لوضع اليد
على الاموال الروسيه المجمده بفعل
العقوبات لانفاقها على اعاده الاعمار
هذا وقال رئيس الامريكي
مع رئيس الروسي اذا اظهر رغبته لانهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا ايضا اوضح ايضا ان
انتصار روسيا في اوكرانيا امر غير وارد
انه لن يتفاوض مع بوتن قبل التفاهم مع
شركائه الاوروبيين وشدد في مؤتمر صحفي
مشترك مع نظيره الفرنسيه
اهميه وجود دفاع اوروبي قوي واكثر فعاليه
الباحث في الشؤون الاقتصاديه والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن بروكسال فابريس مدير تخطيط
السياسات السابق مرحبا
كيف تفهم موسكو استمرار الغرب لا سيما حلف
الناتو من التحذير
لموسكوبان استهداف اي دوله في الحلفا بان
الحلف سيدافع عن ما يسميها الجبهه الشرقيه
المتعلقه بمنع موسكو من مواجهه هي خاطئه
لان روسيا لا تخطط لغزوه اي دوله في نيوتن
فليس هناك امكانيه ولا حاجه ولا ضروره
استراتيجيه اصلا للقيام بذلك وخاصه انه لا
صانع قرار يريد هذا اذا فهذه فكره جنونيه
اذا على الارجح عندما نيته يتحدث عن هذا
الامر وعندما المسؤولون يدلون بتصريحات
كهذه هم فقط يفسرون لسكانهم المحليين
لماذا مهم
وانيته لماذا لا يتدخل في الوضع الاوكراني
مباشره
رومانسي
وهم فقط يرسلون السلاح
ولذلك هؤلاء الناس
فرق كبير بين اوكرانيا واي دوله عضو
فينيتو ولذلك
مؤخرا اشار بشكل مباشر لان انا اوكراني
يجب ان تفكر
باستمرار وضعها المتعلق بكونها دوله وليس
بالانضمام الى نيته
هل تكرار حلف الناتو هذا التحذير لروسيا
هو هي رسائل داخليه لدول الحلف كما يلامح
ويقول الدكتور متوفيتش
والايفون
من النظر الى الحقائق الاساسيه
في اقل من عشره اعوام قامت
بشن حرب عدوانيه ضد جارتها وهي دوله ذات
سياده وهي اوكرانيا بالنظر الى ان
اوكرانيا هي في حقيقه الامر هي دوله
اوروبيه وجزء من هذه المنطقه فمن المشروع
نيته ان يشعر بان روسيا تعتبر تهديد ليس
فقط لاوكرانيا ولكن ايضا لحلفاء الناتو
اذا فمن المنطق في هذه الحاله ان
يذكر بشكل مستمر بان الناتو سوف يحمي
مصالح هؤلاء
الحلفاء بموجب البند الخامس من اتفاقيه
الحلف
يعني لا احد حتى يعني اغلب المحللين الروس
قبيله بدل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كان
يتوقع بان يقدم الرئيس بوتن على غزوه
اوكرانيا لماذا الان همم يمكن استبعاد ان
ان يعني
تتحقق هذه المخاوف الغربيه ولحلف الناتو
بان تقدم ايضا روسيا على توسيع رقعه الحرب
ابعد من اوكرانيا مثلا
عايزين نوال
الكويتيه
لذلك وما هي المنفعه التي ستعود على روسيا
في توزيع النطاق الحرب اذا ليس هناك من
فعل الاطلاق ولا ارى ايضا امكانيه عسكريه
او قدره لروسيا ان تقوم بتوسيع نطاق هذه
الحرب فمن الصعبه ان يكون هناك هزيمه
لاوكرانيا الان ناهيك عن دول اخرى اذا لا
اعتقد ان هذا النوع من المخاوف هو منطقي
وعقلاني بان روسيا يمكن ان تواجه نيته اذا
يمكن ان يكون هناك حرب نوويه بين روسيا
والنيته اذا ما تدخل النيته مباشره في
ازمه الاوكرانيه هذا اكثر اهميه من
السيناري والافتراضي بان روسيا لاسباب غير
معلومه قررت ان تواجهنيته دعونا نتحدث عن
الصواريخ التي انطلقت من اوكرانيا الى بول
ماذا كان الرد من الناتو المسؤولون فيتو
وبشكل رسمي قالوا من البدايه انه ليس سببا
يدعو لي التدخل وليس سببا يجعلنا نقول ان
روسيا قامت به اذا فهذا لا يدعو ان ياتوا
للقيام بهجوم مباشر على موسكو اذن فموقف
النيته كان مختلفا عن الموقف الاوكراني
بالنسبه لهذه القضيه المتعلقه بالصواريخ
وهذا يظهر لنا في المستقبل باننيته حقا لا
يريد ان يشارك مباشره في الازمه
الاوكرانيه اذا لا ارى حقا بانه قد يكون
وضع حقيقي تقوم من خلاله روسيا بالهجوم
على النيته او العكس همم النيته وموسكه
تقول بانهما لا يريدان مواجهه مباشره ولكن
في الوقت نفسه موسكو تقول بان الحلف يدفع
روسيا نحو مواجهه ابعد واوسع ربما من خلال
هذا الدعم العسكري
الصاروخي الغير مح
لاوكرانيا هل فعلا حلف الناتو يريد ان
يدفع بروسيا لمواجهه وان كانت بطريقه غير
مباشره
هو ما هو مرتبط
بالحدود البولنديه والصاروخان
اللذين وقع في اراضي هولنديه اذن فا
بنهايه الامر روسيا روسيا قامت
باطلاقه 100 صاروخ ضد المدن الاوكرانيه
والناس والبنيه التحتيه الحيويه اذا علينا
ان نتذكر الحقائق والمسؤوليه وراء الحقائق
وايضا بالنسبه
واضح اهتماما بان انيته هو تحالف دفاعي
ولا يرغب بان يواجه يقوم باي مواجهه
مباشره
ولذلك هم عليهم ان يقوموا بصدي اي تهديد
متعلق
باستخدام الاسلحه التقليديه او الاسلحه
النوويه والتي نرى عروسه تستخدمها منذ
بدايه هذا الصرايره اذا فواجب نيته هو ان
يعيده تاسيس الردع
والحديث عن
الاسلحه النوويه التي سيكون لها اثار
مروعه اذا فهو ليس من صالح اي طرف ان
يفارقه ما هذا النزاع ولكنه روسيا تودد
استخدام علم النيتو كطريقه
لتحويل الابصار عن الواقع بانها تنهزم على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وان القوات الاوكرانيه
الفعل تحقق الانتصار شكرا فابريس بوتيه في
بروكسل واستنس لايف مطرخوفيتش في موسكو
شكرا لكم معا
قالت المفوضيه الاوروبيه انها بصدد انشاء
محكمه متخصصه بدعم من الامم المتحده
للتحقيق في جرائم الحرب المحتمله التي
ارتكبتها روسيا في اوكرانيا ومقاضاه
مرتكبها هنا يبرز سؤال عن عدم الوجوه
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه التي باشرت
بالفعل تحقيقاتها بشان ما قالت انها جرائم
محتمله في اوكرانيا نتعرف في هذا التقرير
عن اليه اللجوء الى المحاكم المتخصصه
ليست روسيا طرفا في نظام روما الاساسيه
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وليست ملزمه
بالتعاون معها في مثل هذه الحاله الجو
الدول وعاده لتشكيل محاكم متخصصه بقرار من
مجلس الامن حيث تخول الماده الحاديه
والاربعون من ميثاق الامم المتحده لمجلس
الامن السلطه استعمال
هيئات فرعيه لدعم يو تنفيذ تلك التدابير
وقد تضمنت تلك الهيئات محاكم دوليه عن
جرائم خطيره بموجب القانون الانساني
الدولي او في قضايا طلبه الحكومات مساعده
المجلس في التحقيق فيها او محاكمه
المسؤولين عنها مثل المحكمه الدوليه
التي ارتكبت في رواندا عام 94 هناك عقبه
كبيره تتمثل في ان روسيا عضو دائما في
مجلس الامن وبالتالي ستستخدم حق النقض
الفيتو لعدم صدور هذا القرار
على الارض تتواصلوا المعارك في الشرق
الاوكراني فقد نقل مراسل الجزيره في اقليم
دومباس عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان معارك
شرسه تدور على محور مدينه بخمود شمال
سيطره القوات الروسيه على قريتين جنوب
شرقي المدينه واكدت مصادر اوكرانيه من
الجيش يتصدى لمحاولات القوات الروسيه
التقدم شمالا نحو محمود انه كبدهم خسائر
في الافراد والمعدات وفق قولها وذكرت
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه انه تم صده
محاولات روسيه للتقدم في مقاطعه دونيسك
وثلاثه في مقاطعه لغزك
[موسيقى]
موضوع اخر حيث افاده مراسل الجزيره في
انقره ان مجلس الامن القومي التركي شدد في
بيان خطي له صدر عاقبه اجتماعه برئاسه
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان انا انقره ستتخذ
الخطوات اللازمه لعدم السماح بوجود نشاط
اي تنظيم ارهابيين في المنطقه وكان وزير
الدفاع التركيه قد قال انه واشنطن طلبت من
بلاده اعاده النظر في العمليه العسكريه
المحتمله الشماليه سوريا مضيفا انا تركيا
حذرت الدول المتحالفه معها من دعم حزب
العمال الكردستاني
بعد اجتماعه في انقره مع المبعوث الامريكي
السابق لسوريا جيمز جيفري اعلن البنتاجون
ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي عبر لاكر معارضه
البنتاجون القويه لاي غزو بريه في شمال
سوريا اما مظلوم عبد القائد العام لما
تعرف في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
فقد دعى روسيا الى اعتماد مواقف اكثر حزما
وتحمل المسؤوليتها
في ايقاف ما اسماء التصعيد التركي في
المنطقه
مل هي الاستعداداته ومعلنا جاهزيته التامه
بات الجيش التركي في وضع لا ينتظر فيه
الاوامر للتحرك بريا داخل الشمال السوري
لكن ساعه الصفر التي يحسمها عاده القاده
السياسيون قد لا تكون حتميه اذا ما تسنى
لانقر تحقيق اهدافها المحدده دون ما قتال
ذاك احتمال اوحت به تصريحات وزير الدفاع
التركي خلص يا اكار اثر مكالمه هاتفيه من
نظره الامريكي رايد اوستن ليلى الاربعاء
الخميس لكن ما هو اكثر وضوحا كشف عنه اكار
عقبه لقائه الخميس مع المبعوث الامريكي
السابق لسوريه
طلبت اعاده النظر في العمليه العسكريه
المحتمله لكن انقره طلبت في المقابل ايفاء
الجانب الامريكي بتعهداته واضاف الوزير
التركي ان بلاده ستواصل مكافحه ما سماها
التنظيمات الارهابيه التي تهدد امنها
واستقرار حدودها بغض النظر عن الجهات التي
تدعم تلك التنظيمات
تلك التوجهات اعاده تاكيد عليها اجتماع
مجلس الامن القومي التركي الذي تلقى احاطه
بشان الوضع العسكري الراهن وجدد تصميم
انقره على اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه لعدم
السماح بنشاط اي تنظيم ارهابي في المنطقه
وفقا لبيان صادر عن المجلس حتى الان لا
يمكن الجزم بان صفقه المقايضه قد ناضجت
لكن المؤكد ان حاله الحشد والضخ الاعلامي
والتصريحات المتعاقبه عن قرب العمليه
العسكريه وفرت لانقر رافعه ضغط على الدول
المتحالفه معها وخاصه الولايات المتحده
وروسيا اللتين تتهمما بتوفير الدعم
والرعايه للفصائل الكرديه المسلحه
على ان موسكو تواجه ايضا انتقادات من
الجانب الكردي حيث طالبها القائد العام
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم
عبدي بمواقف اكثر حزما داعيا اياها الى
تحمل مسؤوليتها في قاف ما سماه التصعيد
التركيه في المنطقه باعتبارها دوله ضامنه
لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الموقعي مع انقره
اما الضغط على تلك الفصائل فيستمر يوميا
عبر غارات سلاح الجو التركي تحت اسم عمليه
المخلب السيف مصادر محليه اخبرت الجزيره
ان قصف تركيا استهدف مواقع لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيط مدينه منبج
بريف حلب كما اكدت المصادر ذاتها تعرض عده
مواقع لتلك القوات لغارات في ريفي الحسكه
والرقه شمال شرقي سوريا
ادام لينا من انقره محي الدين عثمان
الباحث في مركز الدراسات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه سته ومن اكلاهما
جوشوه لاندس مدير مركز الشرق الاوسط
بجامعه اوكلاهما المختص في الشؤون السوريه
مرحبا بكما سيد محي الدين طبعا المطالب
الامريكيه لتركيا بعدم تطوير عملياتها
العسكريه تتوتر اخرها من لايف اوستن كيف
ستتعامل تركيا معها
تركيا تركيا
وفي هذه
التحدثون عن عمليه ذريه ولكن لا احد يعلم
متى سيحدث هذا اذا فالامر مرتبط بالتوقيت
بالنسبه المخاوف الامريكيه انا اشك بان
تركيا سوف تاخذ بهذه الامريكيه بعين
الاعتبار ذلك لان تركيا كانت دائما تقول
وتتحدث عن كل عملياته العسكريه بان هناك
ارضيتين شرعيتين لعمليتها البريه العسكريه
الاول ان تركيا قامت بتوقيع اتفاقيه
الثنائيه مع العراق
ودوله سوريا
التسعينيات وفي عام 98 اذا اتفقت مع
البلدين للقيام بعمليه عسكريه ضد اي
نشاطات ارهابيه داخل حدوديهما
والثاني هو ان تركيا كانت تفكر في هذا
الامر بانه يعبر عن الحق في الدفاع عن
الذات وهذا الامر يكرر المسؤولون الاطراف
دائما بان ميثاق الامم المتحده والبند
واحد وخمسون يعطي الحقها لتركيا بان تدافع
عن امنها وعن حدودها ضد التوحلات
والنشاطات الارهابيه في تركيا بالتالي
تمتلك الحق كاملا للقيام بهذه العمليه
اطلاقها ولهذا السبب الولايات المتحده
لديها مخاوف
هواوي هواوي
كما يريدون تسميته ولكن الولايات المتحده
حكومتها
تصف هذه المنظمات الحربيه
لاحقا سيد جوشوا الادس هل زياده التواصل
بين تركيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحدد سقف العمليه التركيه في شمال سوريا
والعراق بتقديرك
مايكل
للولايات المتحده في شماليه سوريا وكما
نستدعي الذاكره فان
وائلسيس
حمايه الشعب التركيه اتفقاء مع الولايات
المتحده على
قتالي داعش وبايدن قال انه لن يخرج من
سوريا ان لم يتم اكمال هذا العمل اذا اذا
ما سمحت
لتركيا
بالغزو في نطاق 30 كيلو متر منطقه عاجله
هذا يشمل كوباني
الاكراد في شمال سوريا ويقوض الموقف
الامريكي في سوريا
اذا فادي لحظه مهمه وسوف نرى ما الذي
سيحدث عندما تزداد الامور صعوبه لان تركيا
هي حليف اهم للولايات المتحده من وحدات
حمايه الشعبه الكرديه وهذا يعتبر امرا
واقعا ومفهوما اساسا
امريكا للاكراد في هذه المنطقه واستراتيجي
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما
الذي يرضي تركيا ولا يعني يغضب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه
بالمفهوم التركي طبعا ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه في هذا الملف
ايتين
الامريكيه الحاليه بالنسبه لما يجري في
سوريا وخاصه في الشمال لا يمكن ادامتها
لان الولايات المتحده تستخدم
منظمه ارهابيه ضد اخرى وتركيا تعرض هذه
السياسه منذ بدايتها وتركيا كانت تعرضه كل
انواع الدعم للولايات المتحده في كفاحها
ضد الارهابي في المنطقه لذلك على الارجح
خلق منطقه عاجله سوف يرضي تركيا ومطالبها
والولايات المتحده ايضا تمتلك الفهم
المتعلق
بمطالب تركيا المتعلقه بالدفاع عن الذات
اذا على الارجح سيكون الامر عباره عن
مفاوضات ثنائيه او ثلاثيه فالروس ايضا
لديهم قول في المنطقه وهم اكثر تفاهما
مقارنه بالولايات المتحده ولذلك تركيا
تتوقع من الولايات المتحده ان تكون اكثر
تفهما بالنسبه لي العمليه العسكريه
التركيه اذا
منطقه عازله ترضي اييي تركيا هل يدخل هذا
ضمن حسابات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذه المنطقه بتقديره
ليس كذلك
اكماني بيبول
في الولايات المتحده ينظرون للامر هذا
لانه نوع من التطهير العرقي لان تركيا
الان لديها هدف لان تضع اللاجئين العرب
في هذه المنطقه الحدوديه
وقد راينا هذا في عفرين بالفعل وهذا هو
القلق الاعظم والذي سوف يسبب اضطرابات
كبيره ويولد الكثير من اللاجئين
طيب
السؤال الاخير سيد محي الدين لو سمحت
الان امام يعني يريد ان نفهم خيارات تركيا
امام هذا الرفض الامريكي كما اسلفنا بانه
متوتر ويزداد
وامان بان تركيا لا تريد ربما ان تذهب الى
الى عمل بري يضر به علاقتها بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لو سمحت
يا رب
خطوط حمراء وللاسف يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده
تقوم باجباري الجانب التركي بان يبقى
اللامباليا في ما يتعلق بتجاوز هذه الحدود
الحمراء ولكن هذه ليست قضيه حكوميه بل هي
سياسه الدوله بان تركيا سوف تبقى قويه ضد
اي نشاطات وتحركات ارهابيه في الجزء
الجنوبي من حدودها
ولذا فان تركيا سوف تمتلك القوه الراجعه
في المنطقه وسوف تقوم بالقتال باستخدام
القوه العسكريه الجويه وهذا ان لم تتفق
جراوند فورست الولايات المتحده على
استخدام تركيا للعمليه العسكريه البريه
اذا سوف تجدوا تركيا لا محاله سبيلا دائما
لرجع هذه النشاطات الارهابيه في المنطقه
السيد محي الدين اتمان في انقره والسيد
جوشوه لاندس في اوكلاهما
[موسيقى]
الى الاراضي المحتله حيث شيعه اهالي مدينه
جنين الشهيدين محمد السعدي ونعيم الزبيدي
الى مقبره الشهداء بمخيم جنين في الضفه
الغربيه
واستشهد السعدي و الزبيدي وهما قياديان في
كتيبه جنينه تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
خلال اشتباكات مع قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه
تسللت الى اطراف المخيم وقد مددت الفصائل
والحكومه الفلسطينيه بالعمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه واطالبه المجتمع الدولي
بالتدخل العاجل لحمايه الفلسطينيين هذا
وقالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان المنظومه
الدفاعيه وضعت بحاله استنفار حول غزه
تحسبا لعمليه الانتقاميه من حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صرخته غضب وهتافات تحيي المقاومه واخرى
تطالب بالانتقام من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه الاجواء رافقت موكبه الشيعي شهيدي
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي محمد السعدي ونعيم
الزبيدي في ازقه وشوارع مخيم جنين
حركه الجهاد اكدت انها ماضيه في مواصله
المقاومه لا يمكن لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ان تسلم للاحتلال وانت تثق بهذا الاحتلال
هذه طبيعه الاحتلال يريها للشعب الفلسطيني
وليل العالم كل يوم انه طبيعته اجراميه لا
يمكن التعايش معه لا يمكن لمن يقتل الشعب
الفلسطيني ان نتطاوض معه
والى مقبره الشهداء بمخيم جنين توجه موكب
المشيعين الذي شاركت فيه معظم الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
واعتبرت الفصائل والحكومه الفلسطينيه ان
الحكومتين الاسرائيليتين سابقه والحاليه
وجهان لعمله واحده
وتهديفان الى مواصله حربهما ضد
الفلسطينيين هنا في مقبره الشهداء بمخيم
جنين
غريا جثمان الشهيدين السعدي والزبيدي لين
ضماء الى من سبقوهما من شهداء المخيم
وامام هذا المشهد يقول الفلسطينيين انهم
مستمرون في التصدي للاحتلال وعملياته
العسكريه ضد المخيم ومقاومته
ففي فجر الخميس بدات قوته الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليه عسكريه سريعه في قريه
وادي برقين وحي الهدف على اطراف مخيم جنين
الغربي
القوات الخاصه تسددت الى عمق الحي
ونشره القناصه في بعض البنايات وحاصلت
منزلا بهدف اعتقال مشتبه فيه مطلوب
لاسرائيل
لقوات الاحتلال ودارت اشتباكات المسلحه
بين الجانبين اسفرت عن استشهاد السعدي
والزبيدي واعتقاله فلسطينيين خلال
العمليات العسكريه سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره
جنين فلسطين
وفي تعليق الاستبقيه لتشكيل حكومه برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو قال عمر برليف وزير الامن
الداخلي في حكومه تصريف الاعمال
الاسرائيليه ان اي تغيير على الوضع القائم
في المسجد الاقصى سيقود حتما بل سيقود
حتما الى الانتفاضه ثالثه ودخلت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن برليف قوله ان
اوصله المكلف بتشكيل الحكومه المقبله
باسناد حقيبه الامن الداخلي لشخص اخر غير
ثمار كثير واضاف بارليف الذي كان يتحدث في
تلخيص قبيله تسليم الدفه لخلفه في المنصب
ان نتنياهو يتصرف منه مطلقات شخصيه وليست
رسميه وانتقد بارليف نقل الصلاحيات من
سرايا حرس الحدود في الضفه الغربيه الى
بني كثير وقال ان الضفه الغربيه ارض
المحتله وسياده هناك هي للجيش الاسرائيلي
وحده
جانبه يعقب بن كفير على تصريحاته برليز
هذه بالقول ان اسرائيل ستكون بامان اكثر
بدون برليف وحمله المسؤوليه عن اعمال
العنف قبل تسليمه مهام منصبه وقال ان
ذاكرته ضعيفه انه بذلك يمس سلك الشرطه
والاسرائيليين في ان واحد
في السياق ذاته طلب دبلوماسيان امريكيان
سابقان الرئيس جودا بالتعامل بحزم مع
التداعيات الخطيره المحتمله للحكومه
الاسرائيليه المرتقبه وحذر الدبلوماسيان
في مقال مشترك نشراته واشنطن بوص من
احتمال زياده العنف الاسرائيلي تجاه
الفلسطينيين وزياده النشاط الاستيطاني بعد
التحالف نتنياهو مع احزاب يمنيه متطرفه
وشخصيات مدانه سابقا بتهمه العنصريه مثل
اعتمار بين كثير المثير للجدل
ميمي طمطوم
في الداخل والخارجي بل واقرب حلفاء
اسرائيل
طلب السفير الامريكي السابق لدى اسرائيل
مع حكومه ستكون الاكثر التطرفا منذ تاسيس
اسرائيل
عند تولي حكومه السلطه ورجعها انه في ظل
حكومه متحالفه مع حساب يهوديه متطرفه
زياده النشاط للسطاني ومصادره الاراضي
صينيه وارتفاعه وتيره العنف الاسرائيلي
تجاهل فلسطينيين توقع ايضا ان تحاول
اسرائيل تغيير الوضع الحالي للقدس المحتله
والمسجد الاقصى تضمن المقال الاقرب الى
رساله مفتوحه للرئيس جو بايدن دعوه لاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه الى تحذير اسرائيل من
اتخاذ اي خطوه لضم الضفه الغربيه او تغيير
وضع الحرم القدسي او اطفاء الشرعيه على
البؤر الاستيطانيه
الى الحكومه عبر تحالفاته المثيره للجدل
مع احباب اقصى اليمين لم تتوقف الادانه
والانتقادات للاسوء المرتقب من سلطه
الاحتلال اتفاق نتنياهو مع حزب القوه
اليهوديه بقيادته
لتولي حقيبتي وزاره الامن الداخلي قد تكون
له نتائج وخيمه لا تختصر بنخفير سياسيون
متطرف معروف بتصريح المعاديه للعربي وفي
سجله ادانه بتهمه العنصريه
ملامح الحكومه المنتظره كلها اخطار محدقه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه ومستقبل المفاوضات وحل
الدولتين يا سلام مر الى سلام شبه مستحيل
قد تشهده القضيه الفلسطينيه في ظل حكومه
اسرائيليه هي الاكثر تطرفا منذ تاسيس
الكيان المحتل
غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه
عضو الكونجرس السابق عن الحزب الديمقراطي
مرحبا محمد الدكتور غسان هل الضغط
الامريكي لعدم تولي الامين متطرف وزارات
مهمه امنيه على سبيل المثال اي جدوى في
المعادله الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه الداخليه
الداخليه
بعض لازم ان هناك جدوى تذكر يمكن تعويلها
على اي ضغط امريكي حقيقي
لسني نتنياهو عن التحالف مع هذه الاحزاب
الاكثر تتطرفا في اسرائيل
والنتيجه الوحيده التي يتوقعها من مثل هذا
التطور هو ان العلاقه والدعم الامريكي
لاسرائيل سيكونوا محرجا بعض الشيء
للحكومه الامريكيه كما سيكون الامر عليه
مع الحكومات الاوروبيه ذات الطبع
الليبرالي لانها ستكون محرجه في التعامل
مع مثل هيك حكومه ولكن المصالح المشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ستكون اكبر
من مثل هذا الاحراج وربما سيكون هناك بعض
انتقادات لفظيه كما كانت عليه الامور
سابقا همم لكن
تتوقع ان ان ان تتجاوز الولايات المتحده
حدود بعض الانتقادات اللفظيه الشكليه
الغير جاده سيد رحال ال التحفظ الامريكي
من منطلق خوف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
على تصرف اليمين المتطرف تجاهها
الفلسطينيين ام هو خوف على اسرائيل من
انقسام
محتمل جراء تولي شخصيه مثل البنك كثير
مثلا وزاره امنيه مهمه
ان تعتبره بكلام السيد
في واشنطن هذا الصباح
وعليهم ان يرسله تحذيرا اما بطريقه خاصه
او باي طريقه كانت للاسرائيليين ولهذا
الجناح اليمني الائتلافي من الحكومه
بان الاداره لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي
ايشواسم ورز يقوم فقط باصدار كلمات قاسيه
ضد اسرائيل فقط ان كانت هذه الجماعات
اليمنيه المتطرفه تستمر
[موسيقى]
الاراضي والتسبب
بالدموع للفلسطينيين اذا فهذا التحالف
اليمينيه المتطرف يريد السعي في هذا
المسار وادارته
يجب ان لا تكون خائفه ابدا
وان لا تتردد في اصدار اي كلام او تحركات
حتى ان كان هناك اي استفزازات وتحركات لا
تحسب من قبل هذا التحالف الاسرائيلي ان
حدثت ولا حتى يجب على اداره ان تكون خائفه
من الكونجرس
وهذا
هو محطه الاحراج الحقيقي اذا ما لم يكن
هناك تحرك يتخذ
ضد
هذا التحالف الاسرائيلي
والاستفزاز العدواني والعنف ضد
الفلسطينيين
كيف تفهمون الاصوات من الداخل الاسرائيليه
التي تحذر من وجود شخصيه مثل بني كثير في
وزاره الامن الداخلي في حكومه عتيده مقبله
برئاسه نتنياهو هل يشكل هذا اي فارق ايضا
على الصعيد الداخلي بتقديره
هناك اهميه لمثل هذه الاصوات ويجب اييي ان
نقوم بابرازها قدر الامكان وربما يجب ان
يكون هناك تعاون معها ومحاوله تقويتها
ولكن المؤسف بانه التوازنات في داخل
اسرائيل وهذا ما اظهره الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه الاخيره يشير الى ان هذه
الاصوات العقلانيه نسبيا والتي تخشى على
مستقبل ومصلحه اسرائيل وسمعتها ومكانتها
في العالم همم اصوات خافته وفي التوازنات
الداخليه الاسرائيليه هي اخذه في التراجع
وفي الضعف ربما ان نتائج الانتخابات
الصادمه بالنسبه للعالم بالنسبه لاصدقاء
اسرائيل في العالم ربما انها تشجع بعض
الشيء هذه الاصوات التي تشعر بالقلق على
مستقبل اسرائيل ومستقبل الدعم الغربي
لاسرائيل ولذلك بالرغم من
حدوديه هذه الاصوات الا انها ذات اهميه
وهذا يقودني الى جانب مهم همم وهو كيف
سيتعامل الجانب الفلسطيني والجانب العربي
مع هذا التطور الاخير في اسرائيل لانه هذه
الحكومه القادمه في اسرائيل التي كما اشرت
ستتشكل احراجا لاصدقاء اسرائيل في العالم
سوف تعطي فرصه جديده مهمه للدبلوماسيه
الفلسطينيه ولدي بالمسيل العربيه
لزعزعت بعض جوانب التحالفات الاسرائيليه
مع الدول الغربيه ومع المجتمعات ومع الراي
العام في الولايات المتحده وفي اوروبا هذه
الحاله الجديده يجب استثمارها من جانب
الدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه والدبلوماسيه
العربيه
لمحاوله اجتذاب اكبر قدر ممكن من الضغوط
من الدول الصديقه الاسرائيلي مثل هذه الح
بس السيد رحال همم نتنياهو اتفق اصلا مع
بني كفير ويبدو انه على وشك الاتفاق مع
سموتش همم في حال تم هذا رغم التحفظ
الامريكي ما التداعيات المحتمله للعلاقات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
في حقيقه الامر
سكس اكشن
وانا شخصيا انا الامر سيكون اكثر من مجرد
كلمات للادانه يجب ان يكون هناك تحركات
حقيقيه تحدث ويقول ان الكونجرس الامريكي
يتحمل المسؤوليه هنا لكي يتحرك ايضا في
هذا الصعيد وهذا
الحاليه
اي بان يكون هناك رد من الجانب اليمني في
اسرائيل تجاهها كلمات الادانات هذه اذا قد
يكون هناك
مساعدات ماليه يتم تعليقها ربما حتى اشعار
اخر بدون المخاطره
والمجازفه بالعلاقات الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه
اخرى ومنافعه اخرى ايضا في هذا الصعيد
يمكنه
للحكوماتنا ان تمنح الحكومه الاسرائيليه
كما لا نمنح لاي دوله اخرى في العالم على
الاطلاق ونحن بحاجه الى اعاده فحص بعضها
التي يوفرها دافع الضرائب الامريكان
للحكومه الاسرائيليه لكي تقوم السؤال
الاخير يا دكتور غسان شكرا سيد ذكر رحال
دكتور غسان تحدثت عن ما الذي يمكن ان تقوم
به السلطه الفلسطينيه ال- الان التنسيق
الامن سيكون مع حكومه
يتزرعها او يراسها بن كثير هل وقف التنسيق
الامني هو احد الخيارات المطروحه امام
السلطه لو سمحت
باختصار اعتقد ان قضيه التنسيق الامني
يعني هي قضيه موجوده في الدعايه والاعلام
اكثر ما هي موجوده في الواقع يعني منذ مده
غير قصيره واسرائيل يعني لا تعير اهتمام
يذكر
بالعلاقه الامنيه مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه تتعامل بتردد كبير وقد
تراجعت عمليه تنسيق الامن لدرجه ان
اسرائيل لم تعد يعني تابه بهذا المساله
ولم تعد تعتمد لا من قريب ولا من بعيد على
مثلا هذا التنسيق اعتقد ان الموضوع مبالغ
فيه الى حد كبير وهو في الواقع الذي يقدم
ولن يؤخر على كل الاحوال شكرا لكم الدكتور
غسان الخطيب في رام الله والسيد نكره حال
فيرجينيا
[موسيقى]
عاشت اسبانيا خلال هذين اليومين على تحدي
الامين كبير حزمه من الطرود البريديه
المفخخه والمشبوها ارسلت الى جهه شملت
رئيس الوزراء ومسيره الدفاع والسفير
الاوكراني واخر كان موجهه لسفاره
الامريكيه لكن تم اعتراضه وتفجيرها الشرطه
الاسبانيه قالت ان الرسائل المتفجره جاءت
على خلفيه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا جانبه
قال نائب وزير الداخليه الاسبانيه ان
التحقيق لا يزال في المراحل الاولى ومن
المبكر معرفه الجهه المسؤوله واضاف
المسؤول الاسباني انه ليس هناك اسباب كافي
حتى الان في رفع مستوى التهديد الارهابي
مضيفا ان المؤشرات الاوليات تشير الى
الطرود الملغمه قد ارسلت من داخل الاراضي
الاسبانيه
ارسالوا عبوات الناسفه صغيره في طرود
بريديه في اسبانيا ليست الحادثه الاولى من
نوعها فقد تكررت في عدد من البلدان
اسبانيا نفسها عاشت خلال خمسينيات القرن
الماضي سنوات ناشطه لمنظمه ايتال فيصليه
التي مارست هذا النوع من الهجمات لكن اشهر
المواجهات بل الموجات التي شهدها العالم
كانت ما وقع في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بعد عام 2001 وهناك برزت بشده
ظروف ما يعرف بالجمره الخبيثه وهي بكتيريا
خطيره ارسلت بالبريد الى مؤسسات الاعلاميه
وسياسيين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واصابه جهاز البريد على مستوى البلاد
بالشلال في عام 2018 اعترضت اجهزه الامن
الامريكيه طرودا بريديه مشبوها مرسله الى
عدد من الشخصيات البارزه مثل الرئيس
السابق باراك اوباما في واشنطن ووزيره
خارجته السابقه هل ركليتور وزوجها ايضا في
نيويورك
قروض بريديه متفجره مماثله وصلت عام 2020
الى صناديق بريد شركات تجاريه ومصارف
هولنديه اسفلت عن خسائر ماديه وحالتهالع
بين الموظفين العاملين في مواقع الاحداث
طردوا المفخخ او رساله ملغمه هي عباره عن
عبوه ناسفه ترسل عبر الخدمه البريديه صمت
لكي تجرح او تقتل وتسلم الطرد عند فتحه
الرسائل المفخخه غالبا تكون مصممه لتنفجر
على الفور عند فتح الطرد معنيه جديه
باصابه او قتل المتسلم الذي من المحتمل
الا يكون الشخص المرادته ما حدث في
اسبانيا مثلا هي عبوات مصنوعه يدويا ارسلت
في طرود بنيت بنيت اللون غير متفجرات بل
تحتوي على مسحوق قابل للاشتعال وسلك
تفجيريا يشعلان السلهب مفاجاه هناك طروب
اخرى على جراثيم الجمره الخبيثه المركزه
استخدمت في اعمال الارهاب البيولوجيه عن
طريق ارسال رسائل بريديه تحتوي على جراثيم
منها الجمره الخبيثه ويمكن ان تدخل الجمره
الخبيثه الى جسم الانسان الطريقه الابتلاع
او الاستنشاق او حتى عن طريق اللمس هناك
ايضا ماده الرسينه السامه فقط وضعت في
طرود بريديه استهدفت تسمين الرئيسين
الامريكيين السابقين اوباما وترامب ولا
يعد رسين عنصرا او مركبا كيميائيا بسيطا
بل هو بروتين نباتي مركب شديد التعقيد
وبحسب الخبراء فان التصنيع هذا السم
الفتاك يعد امرا شبه مستحيل لنفهم اكثر
همم هذه الطرود وما الضرر الذي ممكن ان
تلحقه ينضم الينا من لندن السيد افضل
الدراسات الامنيه والعلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه لوفرا البريطانيه سيد افضل
ما رسائل الجهات التي ترسل هذه الطرود
محاوله اغتيال ضد الشخص المعني وفي هذه
الحالات
يكون هناك ماده متفجره او ثم وجه ضد ذلك
الشخص ولكن
هي ليست ناجحه كتقنيه وفي العاده هي
تستخدم ببساطه
للتعبير عن عدم الرضا او الامتعاض ويمكن
ان تستخدم احيانا ايضا
بغيه ارسال نوع ما
من التعبير عن مشكله ما لدى شخص وهذا يعني
بان الكثيرين من من يرسلون هذه الطرود
المفققه هم ليسوا ارهابيين لانهم يعرفون
انها كطرود غير كفئه
ويعلمون ان
الناس او الافراد الذين هم اصلا لديهم
مشكلات نفسيه هم من يستخدمون هذه الطرود
المفخخه واحيانا المجرمون يفعلون ذلك ما
هي الصعوبات الابنيه التي تحول دون كشف
هذه الطرود قبل همم الوصول الى الجهه
المستهدفه
هناك نوعان
من الطرود المفخخه احدها كما قلتم هو
عباره عن قنبله
والاخر هو متعلق ببكتيريا او ماده
كيميائيه اذا عندما نتعامل مع المواد
المتفجره او القنبله من السهل الكشف عنها
باجهزه مثل الاشعه السينيه
ويعرفوا ايضا
اين يمكن نشر هذه الاجهزه ويمكن نشرها في
اماكن محدده في الاماكن التي يتوقع حدوث
هذا
وخاصه فيما يتعلق باجراءات متعلقه
باتخاذ اجراءات كهذه ضد رئيس او رئيس
وزراء او عمده ولكن يصبح الامر صعبا اكثر
عندما نتعامل مع المواد الكيميائيه او
البيولوجيه وهذه بحاجه الى اجهزه متخصصه
ومجسات وهذه متاحه فقط للاستخدام بشكل خاص
حصري على سبيل المثال اذا ما علمنا ان
هناك تهديد ضد همم سفاره على سجل السفاره
الامريكيه فانا متاكد انه في ظروف
كهذه
فيجب فحص كل شخص يدخل السفاره بنسبه
لاسبانيا او اي دوله اخرى
يمكن لهم ان يقوموا باستخدام هذه ولكن ليس
على صعيد روتيني
تحضير هكذا طرود سيد افضل
ويصبح الامر اكثر صعوبه في
تجهيزي سلاح الخبيثه
قوي قوي
السلاح صعب تحضيره وحتى من
يحوز عليه
فقد يضروا بنفسه او بمن حوله ولذلك لا نرى
حقا ان استخدام المواد الكيميائيه او
البيولوجيه منتشرا كثيرا ولكن الطرود
المفخخه
استخدمت
منذ وقت طويل
وتم استخدامها
منذ هذه الاوقات لمده
طويله ولذلك هي تستخدم من قبل شخص عازما
على الاضرار الاخرين شكرا لك السيد افضل
اشرف استاذ دراسات الامنيه والعلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه لافرا البريطانيه في
لندن
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا
موعدنا مع موجزه لاهم الانباء قبل
الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه مونديال قطر
اعرب الرئيس الامريكي عن استعداده للحديث
مع نظيره الروسي اذا اظهر رغبته بانهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا واوضحها بيضا ان انتصار
روسيا في اوكرانيا امر غير وارد
جانبه قال رئيس الفرنسيه من وين ماكرون
فرنسا تدين وجرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها
روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه واكد مكروه
اهميه ان يكون هناك دفاع اوروبي قوي وفعال
تعهد الامين العام يحل في شمال الاطلسيه
الناتو بان الحلف سيدافع عن كل حلفائه
خاصه في الجانب الشرقي من جهته اكد مسؤول
الامن والسياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الحاجه الى صياغه نظام امني جديد
في القاره الاوروبيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه انه واشنطن
احدثت خطرا وجوديا على روسيا انطلاقا من
اوكرانيا ووصف منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا بالكيان الهامشي واتهم نيته بالسعي
لفرض هيمنته على العالم
افردت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره بان الجيش
التركي قصف مواقع لما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه في محيط مدينه منبج بريف حلب
شماليه سوريا وذكرت مصادر محليه للجزيره
ان القصف التركيه شمل ايضا مواقع لما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في رفاي الحسكه
والرقه
كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ان الوزير ابلغ نظيره التركي خلصي اكر
معارضه الولايات المتحده القويه لاي غزوه
بريه تركيه محتمل في شمال سوريا
طلب مظلوم عبدي القائد العام لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه روسيا بتحمل
مسؤوليتها كونها دوله ضامنه لاتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار مع تركيا وباعلاني ما وصفه
بالمواقف الاكثر حسما
افاد هيئه البث الاسرائيليه بان المنظومه
الدفاعيه الاسرائيليه وضعت في حاله
استنفار حول غزه تحسبا لعمليه انتقاليه من
الجهاد الاسلامي وكان شاباني فلسطينيان قد
استشهد واصيب ثالث خلال اقتحام قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمدينه ومخيم جنين
ونعت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي الشهيدين وقالت
انهما من قاده كتيبه جنين وتوعدت بالرد
[موسيقى]
الله
نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن متابعه لا
تنسوا موعدكم بعد قليل مع يوميات
المونديال الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]